over a century after he first appeared
in movies Charlie Chaplin's name it
still conjures images of a funny little
guy in a bowler hat causing mirth
inducing chaos by some measures his
little Tramp is the most famous
character to have ever existed a clown
so beloved that not even Hitler stealing
his moustache could ruin him for us but
what about the man behind the character
born into grinding poverty in Victorian
London Charlie Chaplin rose from the
gutter to become the highest-paid actor
in Hollywood he met with icons courted
revolutionaries and then lived long
enough to see his reputation dragged
through the mud and his adopted country
disowned him they say that behinds the
smile of every clown next his if that's
true then it makes sense that the story
of cinema's greatest clown would be the
most tragic of all when Charles Spencer
Chaplin was born in London on April the
16th 1889 it must have seemed like it
hit the artistic jackpot his mother
Hannah was a singer while his father
Charles Chaplin senior was an
up-and-coming comic barely a year after
young Charlie had been born Charles
senior was touring the USA and pulling
in megabucks
unfortunately though he was doing it
without Charlie or Hannah that spring
1890 Charles senior had walked out on
his wife and his baby son and had taken
his money with him Hannah Charlie and
Charlie's older half-brother Sidney were
plunged into fighting poverty and this
being Victorian England and all biting
poverty really did bite very hard still
Hannah did what she could for her boys
providing for them with her singing work
teaching them her routines much later
Charlie would say his skill as a dancer
singer and mimic came from observing
Hannah as she did the housework by the
age of five young Charlie was able to
mimic his mother's most popular songs
this turned out to be super useful when
one evening in 1894 Hannah's voice gave
out halfway through a performance
Charlie he was watching from the wings
when Hannah stopped singing the manager
simply shoved the child onstage and told
him to do something so Charlie did just
that in front of a cheering crowd he
finished his mother's did
and brought down my house in any other
biography this would be the heartwarming
moment Charlie attained stardom sadly
though there's very little that's
heartwarming about the life of Charlie
Chaplin Hanna's lost voice it wasn't
laryngitis but it was the first outward
sign of the mental illness that was
consuming her on June the 29th 1895 she
was committed to an insane asylum too
young to fend for themselves Charlie and
Sydney they went to the workhouse the
tales of the next few years a
heartbreaking at some points they went
to live with Charlie's father Charles
senior but the abuse they suffered at
his alcoholic hands was so great that
the authorities they were forced to step
in not the Charles senior and sometimes
try to act like a father in 1897 he got
Charlie a gig with a clog-dancing troupe
known as the 8 Lancashire lads but the
troupe it seemed dissolved and Charlie
went straight back to the workhouse on
May the 9th 1901 Charles Chaplin's
senior finally died of alcohol related
illness
not long after Hannah herself only just
back in the boys lives had a final
relapse and was recommitted to the
asylum this time young Charlie he was
completely alone Sidney had taken the
only way out of poverty curd and in
joined the Navy with his mother brother
and father gone Charlie struggled to
survive over the next five years Charlie
worked any job that he could get his
hands on newspaper vendor toymaker
printer doctor's boy whatever paid he
would do it when he couldn't get work
you simply resorted to sleeping rough
although he picked up acting parts on
the side including a one-year run in
1903 stage production of Sherlock Holmes
they were never enough to support his
dream of becoming an actor that finally
changed in 1908 that year Charlie by
then a lad of 19 landed a gig with the
Fred Karno repertoire company although
the work was minor he played the drunk
in a sketch it brought him into contact
with the right people
Stan Laurel for instance was another
cast member perhaps more important still
in 1910 the Fred Karno company gave
Charlie the chance to do something he'd
never dreamed of he was going to tour
America
in the fall of 1912 American movie
producer Mack Sennett was looking to add
new talents to his burgeoning stock of
actors the head of Keystone films Senate
was one of the pioneers cashing in on
the new gold rush in California silent
films were a fresh exciting medium in
1912 where money could be made very
quickly providers of course you could
find the comic talent batty or one of
the best reviewed comics in America was
an English lad called Charlie Chaplin on
a second tour with Fred Carlos company
so Senate set about luring him to
Keystone he offered him one hundred and
fifty dollars a week and the chance of
continuous work Chaplin differed for an
entire year before finally accepting
Senate's terms in November of 1913 not
two weeks later he was Keith stone
studio's newest actor making a living
the first Charlie Chaplin film in
cinematic history debuted on February
the 2nd 1914 and it was not a success
Chaplin and the director Henry Lymon
fell out so badly that lemon cuts most
of Chaplin's gags from the final edit
even had he kept them in it's unlikely
making a living would be fondly
remembered Chaplin's character he was
nasty and unfunny Keystone might have
been feeling at this time that maybe
that made a bad investments in this new
comedian if that thought ever flashed
through Mack Sennett's mind it was soon
gone after making a living wrapped
Senate was at the keystone lot watching
the filming of a short called Mabel's
strange predicament Chaplin was hanging
around hoping to be noticed when Senate
said we need some gags here the producer
pointed at Chaplin and said put on
comedy makeup anything will do Chaplin
went to the props apartments I'm sure
what Senate wants it there he found a
pair of baggy trousers a bowler hat and
a cane as Chaplin later said I had no
idea of the character at the moment I
was dressed the clothes in the makeup
made me feel the person he was I began
to know him and by the time I walked
onto the stage he was fully born that he
was The Little Tramp and he was about to
make Chaplin an absolute fortune in the
Tramp costume Chaplin made the crew on
Mabel strange predicament laughed so
hard the entire Keystone company just
stopped and watched by the end of the
day
Chaplin swore that it never perform
without his new costume again and so it
was that On February the 7th 1914 the
tramps second Keystone picture peered
auto races of
beat Mable strange predicament in
theatres it was an instant hit you can
clearly see the effect the Tramp had on
Chaplin's career over 1914 Chaplin made
32 more films for Keystone when its
contract ran out in December a bidding
war erupted that made Senate's initial
offer of a hundred and fifty dollars a
week look pitiful sna Studios offer
Chaplin $1,250 a week plus a ten
thousand dollar signing bonus not being
an idiot Chaplin said yes the next few
years saw Chaplin's star go supernova at
SNA he rebooted The Little Tramp in 1915
s for tramp making the character mobbed
sweet-natured
the new approach was so successful that
mutual films poached Chaplin from SNA
with an offer of $10,000 a week at age
26 Chaplin was now the highest-paid
actor in all of Hollywood over the next
two years Chaplin shot 12 shots for
mutual he later called those years the
happiest of his life not that happiness
stopped him from moving on at the end of
1917 Chaplin terminated his mutual
contract he built his own studio signing
a deal with first national to release
his pictures without any interference no
yet 30 Chaplin was now the most famous
movie star in America and his next move
allows to conquer the world the next
decade was a golden time for Chaplin the
filmmaker his first feature the kid came
out in 1920 the gold rush possibly his
best work followed in 1924 in 1928 he
made the circus a film Orson Welles the
director of Citizen Kane the greatest
movie of all time once called the
greatest movie of all time it was also a
golden time for Chaplin the producer in
1919 he ditched First National and
co-founded United Artists with Mary
Pickford and DW Griffith giving them
total control over their pictures so at
this point you might be thinking well
this could be the rest of the video just
Simon throwing movie names at you and
telling you how amazing they were and
how a rich and famous Charlie Chaplin
became but that's not what happens if
the decade following 1918 was a golden
time the Chaplin's public faces it was
far less so for his private one it was
in this period that the darkly flawed
Chaplin emerged it began in the fall
of 1918 when Mildred Harris told Chaplin
that she was pregnant the two had
started seeing each other earlier in the
year in secret in secrets because while
Chaplin missed nearly 30 Harris was
barely half his age under California law
having sex with someone aged only 16
with statutory rape so when Harris told
Chaplin she was pregnant it sent the
star into panic mode that October 1918
Chaplin married Harris in a secret
ceremony not long after a Harris's
pregnancy it vanished suspecting his new
wife had tricked him Chaplin resolved to
make her life hell over the next two
years Chaplin badly mistreated Harris
although he was never physical he was
mentally abusive ignoring her belittling
her and calling her an idiot
in 1920 when Harris was 18 Chaplin
finally got her pregnant for real and
then divorced at it wouldn't be his only
icky behavior that decade the same year
he divorced Harris Chaplin met lead to
gray then a mere 12 years old Chaplin
kept her close for the next few years
until great finally turned either 15 or
16 depending on which sauce you read and
then he seduced her today we definitely
call this behavior grooming even in the
freewheeling 20s it was pretty damn
shocking on of them the 23rd 1924 Lita
told Chaplin that she was pregnant once
again pasty to avoid a statutory rape
charge Chaplin married her in New Mexico
once again the little tramp made their
marriage a misery
nor was it just chaplains home life that
was suddenly devoid of laughter the same
month Chaplin married Lita Chaplin was
on a yacht when producer Thomas Ince
died in mysterious circumstances it's
long been rumored the Chaplin was
sleeping with newspaper Baron William
Randolph Hearst Smith since that Hearst
accidentally shot ins while trying to
kill Chaplin but if those rumors were
not bad enough the divorce suit that
leader filed in 1927 it was even worse
after two miserable years with Chaplin
Lita was a broken woman in her court
filing she accused Chaplin of trying to
force an abortion onto her of mental
cruelty and of forcing her to
participate in sex acts so disgusting
there's no way we could realistically
describe them here without getting
probably our entire channel bans
although Chaplin saddled the suit out of
court for $600,000 the scandal consumed
him Chaplin was used to being a
household name and now he was a
lightning rod for those who hated the
loose morale
of the age still like the 1920s they
ended on a high the movie the circus was
a major success and Chaplin quickly
began work on a film that would become
city lights by now though strong clouds
they were gathering two events were
about to happen if it would shake up
Chaplin's world one on Wall Street the
other very much in the town where he
made his fortune on October the 6th 1927
a little film called the jazz singer was
premiered the tale of a white Jewish man
who blacks up to become a jazz legends
the film would probably be rather
forgotten today if it was not for one
major technical innovation the jazz
singer was the first film in American
history to feature a synchronized
soundtrack the age of talkies had
finally arrived famously silent stars
like Chaplin were dismissive of the new
technology while preparing city lights
Chaplin claims that the new fad wouldn't
even last six months there were no such
delusions over the next world shake-up
though two years after the jazz singer
premiered the New York stock market gave
a final sigh and collapsed into a pile
of broken American dreams the wreckage
of that fateful day would become the
Great Depression and it affected
everyone
but while the advent of talkies was
ruinous for most silent stars the Great
Depression gave Chaplin's work a sudden
urgency for Jazz Age audiences Tramp
with a heart of gold was as exotic as
superheroes are to us today for film
goers in the 1930s he was the exact
tonic they needed just by being a silent
anachronism when it appeared in 1931
city lights was a standout success
not that Chaplin enjoyed the accolade
seemingly depressed by the way the world
and his art form were going he left the
states in 1931 and embarked on a world
tour during this time they act he met
everyone from Albert Einstein - Mahatma
Gandhi but it was what Chaplin witnessed
in Europe that concerns us today the
rise of automation and nationalism was
fraying the consonants at the edges when
Chaplin returned to Hollywood in July of
1932 he was obsessed with doing
something about these twin evils on one
level that meant starting work on modern
times his 1936 satire of capitalism on
another it meant leaning towards
politics for the first time in his life
and this meant becoming open
sympathetic towards communism this
radical shift it certainly didn't go
unnoticed in 1939 Chaplin began shooting
his first real talkie the Great Dictator
a satire of nationalism and general and
Adolf Hitler in particular it was made
at a time when the u.s. was officially
neutral in the war engulfing Europe so
in the film premiered in 1940 with this
political ending speech audiences didn't
see the Little Tramp exhorting the end
of a horrific war they saw a suspected
communist trying to round left-wing
ideology down their throats in 1938 the
house on American Activities Committee
had come into existence following a
report that Hollywood was teaming with
Reds now Chaplin he was confirming their
worst suspicions and boy did he ever
confirm them after the attack on Pearl
Harbor dragged the u.s. into World War
two Chaplin became a professional
agitate for the Red Army at an
ill-advised speech in New York he called
Stalin's purges a wonderful thing and
followed up by saying the only people
who objected to communism are the Nazi
agents in this country in the context of
a war in which the u.s. was allied with
the USSR these comments may have seemed
justifiable but for those who already
suspected Chaplin of anti-americanism
this it was just fuel for the fire by
late 1942 prominent media personalities
were questioning Chaplin's commitment to
America all it would take would be one
giant anti-communist panic and his
reputation could be utterly destroyed
but this was the early 1940s there was
no way America could just be a few short
years away from being consumed in a Red
Scare
[Music]
April the 11th 1947 is the day Charlie
Chaplin lets the fuse on the bomb that
destroyed his career that day he
released his movie Monsieur Verdoux a
black comedy featuring Chaplin as a
serial killer who marries and murders
old ladies for the money
Monsieur Verdoux almost bankrupted
United Artists it led to Charlie Chaplin
being blacklisted and nearly indicted by
the house on American Activities
Committee today the film is regarded as
a late Chaplin classic but in 1947 it
was the equivalence of watching mr.
Rogers kick a puppy to death while
wearing a swastika do you understand
just how Monsieur Verdoux came to
annihilate everything Chaplin held dear
we need to get back in time to 1941 as
you'll probably remember this was when
Chaplin was just starting to mouth off
about how great Stalinism was it was
also when he met a young actress named
Joan Barry Barry was slightly older than
Chaplin's previous conquests being the
grand old age of 21 when Chaplin was 42
they started an affair but it wasn't
long before things got out of hand
in 1943 Barry sued chaplain for
impregnating and then abandoning her
unfortunately for Chaplin prosecutors
decided to hit him with everything that
they had Chaplin was charged under the
1910 Mann Act better known as the white
slave Traffic Act designed to stop
people taking prostitutes over state
lines it wound up being so broadly
worded that anyone who brought someone
to another state even for consensual sex
could be charged and this was exactly
what Chaplin had done the trial it was a
media circus
the phrase Charlie Chaplin on trial for
white slavery was simply too
irresistible while Chaplin was acquitted
the smoke now billowing around him
convinced many that there was a dark
fire burning behind his public persona
and the thing is they weren't really
wrong we've already heard how
atrociously Chaplin treated the women in
his life and he really was sympathetic
to communism it also didn't help that
during his trial had started an affair
with another eighteen-year-old girl
called lunar O'Neill but the Bary trial
that was what turned everyone on him
notorious columnist Hedda Hopper joined
forces with FBI director J Edgar Hoover
to destroy The Little Tramp in the
Senate William Langer of North Dakota
started advocating for Chaplin's
deportation in 1947
dawned Chaplin he was in dire need of a
comeback United Artists was running out
of money
his reputation it was in ribbons what
was needed was another city lights a
film to remind the public just why they
loved him instead the public they got
Moss you ever do a film that ends with
Chaplin comparing the capitalist system
to mass murder and implicating every
single American in war crimes for the
atomic bombing of Hiroshima it was the
last straw in Washington the house on
American Activities Committee informed
Chaplin he would likely be subpoenaed
while he never was the McCarthy i'ts
they still destroyed him that November
1947 the Hollywood ten were jailed for
refusing to name and shame are the
communists in the wake of the scandal
300 more stars were blacklisted
including Chaplin still Chaplin was
Chaplin which meant that he had money
and influence at his disposal that
others didn't have even while on the
blacklist he founds money to crank out
limelighter
parts multi-part touching picture about
an aging clown whose glory days are over
scheduled for a September 1952 release
Chaplin decided to travel to Europe to
drum up publicity on September the 18th
Chaplin and his now wife Oona boarded a
ship headed for England they wouldn't
see America again for two decades the
next day the Attorney General cancelled
Chaplin's reentry visa despite being in
the US for 40 years the star had never
thought to trade his British passport
for an American one and now America had
blocked him from returning
when limelight was released in the u.s.
it was picketed by morality Crusaders
and end communists no longer welcome in
his adopted home hated by the America
that had once embraced him Chaplin was
suddenly as homeless as the Little Tramp
his days as the greatest star in
Hollywood they were over
[Applause]
the rest of Charlie Chaplin's life can
be easily divided into two chapters the
one where everyone hated him and the one
where they finally accepted him too late
after settling in Switzerland with ona
in January of 1953 Chaplin slowly
started working his way into the
European film system in 1957 he released
a king in New York about a king who
flees into asylum in the USA and suffers
much of the same persecution that
Chaplin did although the script went out
of its way to portray Americans as
fundamentally decent America they
weren't listening the movie it was
banned in most states for being an
American this disappointment more or
less set the stage for the next decade
at one point Chaplin considered reviving
The Little Tramp as a lone survivor of a
nuclear holocaust only to instead Megg
1967's
a countess from Hong Kong a film in
which the only gag seems to be Marlon
Brando repeatedly being caught with a
nubile young woman in his bedroom it
probably didn't help that Chaplin's
health it was failing after a series of
strokes across the 60s had been left
partially disabled it was in this sorry
state that he started work on his final
project the Freak was to be Chaplin's
coda the story of a South American girl
who grows angel wings and becomes hunted
and persecuted it was intended to cap
his life's work sadly he never got made
as the 60s became the 70s Chaplin
suffered yet more strokes by 1974 he was
wheelchair bound and in need of care
although he shot some test footage for
the Freak everyone working with him knew
the director wouldn't survive long
enough to get the picture made on
Christmas Day 1977 Charlie Chaplin
suffered a final cataclysmic stroke in
his sleep and he died at age 88 despite
a brief return to the States five years
earlier to collect an honorary Academy
Award he was still living in exile still
sure America would never truly want him
back normally this would be the point
where we concluded with a quick overview
of Chaplin's life to try and make some
sense of his historical standing but not
this time
because fate it's got one last ghoulish
twist in store for the little trap in
March of 1978 two refugees from
communist Eastern Europe dug up
Chaplin's corpse and they took it
hostage
for next eleven weeks Chaplin's body
remained missing finally in late May of
1978 Swiss police observed one of the
grave robbers trying to call owner with
a ransom demand he was arrested and
Chaplin's missing body was located it
was quickly re-entered this time under a
concrete slab awful as this story is we
can't help but think that maybe Chaplin
would have seen some potential in it the
two grave robbers they turned out to be
dispossessed immigrants living on the
breadline who wanted to make some quick
cash to support their families while the
little tramp never did anything as
desperate as they did in most other
respects his life it wasn't too
dissimilar maybe we just researched this
video too long but you can almost
imagine a darker version of Charlie
Chaplin making that film you can always
picture the tramps oblivious faces he's
accidentally roped into grave robbing
lured by the promise of money for food
maybe it's fitting because Chaplin's
films were some of the first that really
sympathized with the poor with their
struggles their hopes and their dreams
using the magic of cinema he conjured
stories from their hardscrabble lives
and he turned them into masterpieces not
just of comedy but of empathy too he may
have sometimes been cruel sometimes been
foolish sometimes simply been a raging
egomaniac but Charlie Chaplin he was
also the greatest clown who ever lived
tragic as his life was he did succeed in
bringing joy to millions so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do give us a thumbs up
below and don't forget to subscribe
we've got brand new videos just like
this several times a week if you look it
was something else to watch why not
check out another channel I do called
today I found out you'll find a link to
that below and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]